it's important for all of us to know
that at the end of the day you know if
they were to choose to activate some of
their sleeper cells and places like Los
Angeles because they are here or in
places like in Michigan etc then it's
game over they know that the United
States either alone or with the
coalition will go into Tehran it will be
there within you know 12 to 24 hours
this is the Rubin report and I'm Dave
Rubin and here's a quick reminder that
the Rubin report community is here we've
got ad free video and audio podcast and
news feed you can communicate with me
directly as well as other fans and much
more oh and it's totally troll and bot
free believe it or not sign up at Rubin
report comm or search the Reuben report
in the Apple App Store or on Google Play
and now more importantly joining me
today is a former CIA ops officer a
political analyst and a national
security expert Brian Dean right welcome
back to the Rubin report pleasure
brother I had you on here about four
years ago 18 Studios ago
feels like 27 lives ago yeah here we are
we got a lot to do and you've become an
all right gay Nazi which congratulations
very exciting no I'm honor proud I do
wonder though at the Klan meetings dude
your husband where like the rainbow hats
steal the rain well they make you wear
the rainbow cat as a gay well incredible
yeah great great development for you and
your family little did you know four
years ago when we sat down that so much
was gonna happen yeah here we are
alright I'm really glad to have you here
for for many reasons before we get into
Iran before we get into the deep state
before we get into the the split of the
Democrats the rise of the socialist and
the whole thing former CIA ops just give
me a little recap of what got you into
it what does that actually mean and then
we'll take it away on current events so
back in the early 2000 just before 9/11
I was interested in national security
and State Department and CIA were both
options I decided that after looking at
each the CIA made the most sense for me
it was a little bit more cowboy which
coming from farm and ranch in the
western part of this country it was just
it was it fit me better so I applied
move forward to the application process
took a couple gear
and ended up working his way what they
called a clandestine service trainee
program was there for a couple years and
then sent out into the field so what was
it like being in the field as a CIA guy
you know just after 9/11 it was a it was
an incredibly difficult and challenging
time you know we didn't know how many
more threats were going to be actualized
you know how many more people were going
to be killed and so it became a very a
very intense time to be in the
intelligence community but it was also
thrilling you know at a very young age I
was 24 25 and you're out in the field
doing incredible stuff meeting with the
bad guys who are good for you and it was
an incredible opportunity to know that
what you were doing every day helped
ensure that people back home didn't
didn't die how do you figure out which
bad guys are good for you oh there is
that question you can answer yeah so
there is there's a vetting process right
you first start with what do you need to
know and know a particular part of the
world on a particular issue right so
once you do that you go through a target
analysis and you figure out who has the
information in that organization or that
piece of knowledge that you need and
then you target that individual and then
you you approach them in some capacity
and then you build a relationship and
you not only ensure that they are who
you thought that they were to be you
then make sure that they're compatible
in terms of living a clandestine life
with you as an intelligence officer so
that is a very long process or it can be
but in those early days we were
recruiting people to be informants for
us with not a lot of scrutiny because we
just had so little information and the
threat was so profound and it was so
immediate alright so we could do CIA 101
the whole time for people that want that
we'll link to our old interview because
I want to I want to catch up because we
hadn't had you on in a while and when we
booked this this was before this Iran
world war 3 things happen what's
happening
well apparent arose McGowen on Twitter
well not only that but world war 4 has
also begun there's a lot of Wars coming
out well that's exactly why I wanted to
start with this because it seems to me
that if you're paying attention to
social media as it does to most things
we've ramped everything up to crazy
levels beyond imagination it is so hard
to find sort of clear sane non-extremist
voices in the midst of all this I
consider you one of those people so can
you talk to me about what's going on
with Iran and are we in World War 3 or
we are not and inaudible all right well
now we have the quote for those of you
all right so to understand what's
happening you have to step back and ask
yourself the question you know what does
Iran want ultimately right
in general what this regime wants is
both stability and survival more than
anything else so whatever it does in
terms of international affairs domestic
affairs it's all designed to make sure
that the regime continues so they have
red lines they have red lines internally
in terms of how far they what the
populace go in terms of demanding
certain things and then abroad you know
they'll push as far as they can knowing
full well that the United States and the
West and Israel at some point will say
that's a bridge too far and they will
pound the living hell out of Tehran so
they're always poking the bear they're
always challenging that red line so it's
important for all of us to know that at
the end of the day you know if they were
to choose to activate some of their
sleeper cells and places like Los
Angeles because they are here or in
places like in Michigan etc then it's
game over they know that the United
States either alone or with a coalition
will go into Tehran and we'll be there
within you know 12 to 24 hours
okay so let's pause there for a moment
because that was a bit of knowledge so
Iran basically has sleeper cells for in
western cities you just said Los Angeles
we're in Los Angeles Michigan I'm sure
in European cities so if we know these
things exist what are we doing to
actually disrupt these yeah well cells
so both the the FBI and the CIA have
long known that the the tez bull on Iran
have operated these these sleeper cells
and so they've kept a pretty good pulse
on these folks but the issue is do you
know about all of them right and because
you have to be perfect 100% of the time
and they only have to be perfect or
executable once right to to implement
something horrific in the US homeland so
we have a good pulse of what they're
doing and where they are who they are
but do we know all of them I can almost
assure you that the answer is no so
as they sort of push what that red line
is we've had a policy of what maybe the
last 10 or 15 years or at least the
Obama policy we kind of let them do what
they wanted to do right and so now Trump
has kind of flipped this thing on his
head so what do you make about the
strike and what is Trump doing here yeah
so the Supreme Leader never saw this
attack coming
he had buffaloed as I say or my family
says on a ranch in Oregon right with a
buffaloed Bush and Obama for many many
years that that we had certain red lines
that we didn't want to start this world
war 3 so we allowed them that is the
Iranians to do all kinds of you know
poor or terrible horrific activities
throughout the Middle East and indeed
the world we would we would give them
enough leash to attack us through this
Soleimani and the cuts force and
Hezbollah and whatnot what were our red
lines actually like what would have been
the thing that would have changed the
equation on our side
well that's that really is the question
I don't think any of us really knew
certainly with inside the intelligence
community because we have the infamous
Obama red line in Syria that have been
worse you know we just erased that one
and moved to somewhere different so I
don't think the Iranian leadership ever
quite knew where the United States would
with if the switch would flip other than
an attack in the homeland certainly they
learned that after the 9/11 attacks when
we immediately went to Afghanistan we
started making noise elsewhere I think
most of this is public knowledge but the
Iranian government very quietly reached
out and said look we don't we will stay
on the good boy list you know just don't
invade so the upshot is that they know
that we will hit a point where we say
enough and I don't think they thoughts
will Imani would be the in all of his
shenanigans would be it but here we are
right so what do you make of what Trump
did here because it's like if you listen
to the critics it's like Oh Trump
doesn't know what he's doing there's no
plan for after etc etc and it's I'm
starting to think if this guy doesn't
know what he's doing and he has no plans
what does that say about the experts
because he keeps one up in the aspirate
so what's going on here yeah so I think
he did it the right thing right so I
friends who work in Special Forces
community and they were all universally
thrilled at what happened soleimani has
so much button on his hands has maimed
and killed more people not just
Americans but Iraqis and others
so the the man earned his death the
question is so what comes next and I
think people could rightfully and should
be asking that question right and is
this gonna cause World War three some of
that is is hyperbole but some of its
appropriate release ask so the answer is
no we're not going to be going into
World War three the only thing that that
would change that calculus would be
whether Moscow and Beijing suddenly
started moving troops into and/or backed
Iran basically wanted to use them as
some sort of forcing function and this
incident to create World War three right
I don't even think they would move their
troops in Taurus I say there's something
grandiose like that now suddenly we're
looking at a very different prospect of
conflict on a global level if Russia and
China moved into to Iran right so they
have a degree of relationship but I'm
talking about physical assets into Iran
to make clear that this is the
equivalent of that World War one you
know assassination of the the prince in
Sarajevo right the people just to be
clear that that's a pretty far off crazy
thing called over X if you're just
listening to the pundits these days it's
like anything's on the table like the
Martians are landing and you know in the
Intelligence Committee we talk about low
medium and high degrees of confidence
that something could have happened all
right I think that most of us would say
that we have high degree of confidence
that is extraordinarily likely that
Russia and China would ever get involved
in this kind of conflict one because
Russia's economy is the size of Italy I
mean they they're have a lot of internal
struggles themselves and China
fundamentally opposed energy is
concerned about making sure that his
stability of his country remains the
most important priority and then they
continue to grow economically because of
the number of people in that country
they need to have continued economic
growth so that is their focus in their
goal and that's why they want stability
so for them to step into this conflict
and create some sort of horrific outcome
like World War three it's just
extraordinarily unlikely right in terms
of degrees of confidence I would say we
have high degree in confidence that's
not going to happen so the question is
what will Iran do next right so you're
going to see and folks are talking about
this absolutely a degree of pushback
whether it's from cyberattacks the usage
of Hezbollah they're already talking
about that is the Iranian leadership
talking about targeting you know
military personnel and and locations
throughout the Middle East in particular
we expect that the administration
expected that the Pentagon when they
authorize a strike makes
did that that's why you're seeing this
flood of personnel a lot of my friends
going into the Middle East right now and
that is to to make the price of any kind
of retribution or any kind of attack by
Iran the price will go up dramatically
how do we send that message beyond bombs
and killing people like do we actually
go on the ground and talk to contacts
and say guys okay you saw what we did we
know you're planning to do a couple
things here and there but you know do we
really give the hint like well I guess
Trump sort of did it with this tweet
right his tweet about 52 insights that
we've got I mean is that really how it
works like we get down there and talk to
them about that sort of all I think that
the talking that West your house is on a
list basically well I think the talking
that was done was a missile going into
Seoul him on his head yeah right and so
I think the Trump administration very
wisely he said look we have tried
diplomacy with these clowns and they've
continually lied to us about say their
nuclear program if you recall in January
of 2017 Israel did an incredible
operation where they went into Tehran
they grabbed a bunch of nuclear material
that I should say little documentary
based material from this warehouse in
Tehran took it back to Israel that
basically showed that Iran was playing a
game they wanted to make sure that they
held on to their nuclear program the
ability to move forward very very
quickly so there's no real intention by
the regime to give up that that nuclear
capability what do you make of sort of
the set of people that think that just
because you signed something it has
meaning like so like the Iran nuclear
deal just any deal the climate power
succour the Paris climate Accords
like we sign something and that
inherently means that it's real but
that's really not how the world works is
it if you have a document an agreement a
treaty that is signed it is only as
effective as the parties engaged or
involved in tend to carry it forward
right particularly with some degree of
hammer if people find a short I mean
this is what we've experienced with
Russia and some of the START treaty etc
right they were constantly cheating
because they believed that the United
States wouldn't respond in any kind of
intense or a retaliatory way whether it
be sanctions you know beyond what we've
already done to something more kinetic
right the military's right so everybody
who signs any kind of DOC
is always sitting back and making the
calculus for asking can we push this
further can we do more can we sneak
right North Korea with this nuclear
program was a great example of doing
exactly that and it's gotten away with
lying to the world and continue to march
forward irrespective of the silly
sanctions that we and that's what you're
talking about earlier about you just
keep pushing the redline because if you
know the guy on the other side isn't
ever going to push back you can you can
move that thing right pretty significant
it's important and I think you and I
have spoken about previously we hear a
lot right now in the media folks are
talking about you know get us out of the
Middle East
you know get us out of Iran and Iraq and
all these places we shouldn't be there
and that's true
we shouldn't be there yeah why are we
there right so so given me a lot of my
good libertarian sighs so let's have
that conversation so it's good that we
killed soleimani
that the government in Iran is bad but
why the hell are we there to begin with
right we are there because Iran and Iraq
and the Middle East have oil right all
these countries have oil the global
economy is built on oil so it's great
the United States has become a next net
exporter of oil super but the rest of
the world continues to be net importers
so as long as these folks whether it be
Iran or Iraq either control the oil or
through the Strait of Hormuz they
control the ability of that oil to get
to market we are stuck in the sandbox
right so if we want to change this
conversation if we want to basically
make the Middle East the equivalent of
what you know happened in the 90s in
Rwanda where the hoodoos and dudes we're
killing each other if we want to look
the Sunnis and the Shia's slaughter each
other and really the world doesn't care
then we have to remove the the impetus
for us to be there the first is why do
we care we have to change our energy
policy so if you if you're angry about
the fact that we're in the Middle East
and we have troops there then you have
to be on board with changing our energy
energy policy so what do you make of the
argument so you can do it two ways so
the libertarian argument is just get the
hell out of there these aren't our Wars
these are sectarian conflict if existed
forever they're gonna last longer than
we're ever going to exist that's one
side but the other side is well you
broke it you fix it sort of so it's like
Iraq we actually were turning it around
you know where we regardless of whether
you want you thought it was a good idea
to go in or not
weapons mass destruction the rest of it
they were having free and fair elections
basically and then we just left you know
we announced the day
Obama said we're getting out on this day
we left the met it fell apart how do we
negotiate that so you have to set back
and ask the question from a foreign
policy perspective why the hell we
involved in the world what is our
ultimate goal and most smart people will
say that we want the world to be more
democratic because the more democratic
the world is the less likely that the
nations who are democracies will get
involved in conflict and war right so
this is sort of foreign policy 101 so
the question is how do you move nations
from being autocratic or anything less
than a full democracy to to some shader'
variation of a healthy democracy now
President Bush's idea the
neoconservative belief was we could do
it be at the barrel of a gun well oops
that didn't work out right not only did
they view us ultimately as Outsiders
invading the nation but they weren't
really ready for a true commitment to
democracy which requires a degree of
education of the people right to
understand what their obligations are
right that's what I'm saying if we had
stayed longer and I'm not saying we
should have but had we stayed longer
once they had some elections had we
stayed longer to build some institutions
and that sort of thing
yeah it's almost like it could have
worked there were signs that it could
have worked but what is the ultimate
benefit for the American people to go in
a nation build in a place like Iraq or
any nation right so we have to ask
ourselves the questions as there are
hundreds and hundreds of nations around
the world many of which are not
democratic why are we going to get
involved in that one and one of the
things that I actually think the
president drum does correctly perhaps in
his New York braggadocious way is he
says well what are they giving us like
what do we get in exchange and that's
actually a good and important thing to
ask right because we shouldn't be going
into Zimbabwe right and in trying to
correct all the ills of Mugabe and all
those shenanigans right because what do
they given us nothing we would invest
our time and treasure into a place like
Zimbabwe and we'd be getting very little
to nothing in return
other than a commitment to the world and
to ourselves and hism Bob Wian people
that work right into democracy there and
more democracy means less Global War
right so we have to rack and stack or
prioritize we're involved in the world
so a rocket around the reason that we
want to be there why we give two bits
about the place is because of this
commitment not only just to democracy
but because I have something
they have not just we but the global
economy so if you were to withdrawal
right and just completely let the place
go and and be as it is you you better
have a backup in terms of a global
energy policy it doesn't require that
stuff because if if that price of oil
quadruples or you know goes up by 10 20
percent or x whatever number it might be
and you start having global recessions
and depressions now we understand the
cost of our inaction right so there is a
cost to just completely pulling out are
you kind of surprised that Trump seems
to understand all this yeah in a weird
way nobody like I I have had concerns
about his temperament I have finally
wait we should pause for a moment and
say you you are a lifelong Democrat yeah
here we are
I know the feeling my friend who wrote a
great you wrote a great piece on
foxnews.com about the split of the
Democrats and I've been screaming about
this for years but but why do you think
Trump gets this like he's not a
politician he wasn't a foreign policy
guy you asked him five years ago to put
his finger on a map and [ __ ] who knows
what he would have found I mean what is
it about him that you think understand
this or is is he listening to better
generals than the guys before we're
listening to like what what's going on
here well a couple things how do we
diagnose why President Trump is the wave
he isn't in and indeed that he's
effective I think we could probably
through our program and that but the
other side is I think the American
people recognize is something was
important in that man that he could
serve an important role and that is a
fact that he is he's basically a walking
human firecracker right and he went to
Washington to just blow stuff up because
most of us were sick and tired of the
way the Washington was working and we
might talk about all right can we have a
little bit more presidential well when
you elect a firecracker you're gonna get
what you get right so what I think that
he is doing well is he's asking really
important questions that Washington has
always assumed that they've we've asked
an answer like well of course we're
gonna be absolutely committed to NATO at
all times well wait a minute these
a-holes are contributing that you know
their dues so what are we gonna continue
to pay for it like go after yourself I
mean that's basically Trump's attitude
and it's like yeah that's exactly what
should be happening right there should
be nothing so sacred on the table that
we can't ask a question as to or why are
we doing it that way
so I think that that is a
good thing that the presidents bring it
to the table and I think that he is
bringing that that outsider's
perspective and asking really good
questions that might seem to be crazy to
the to the New York and Washington elite
but I should think most people in Middle
America are like yeah we agree with you
that makes sense
yeah all right so with that in mind so
Trump comes in basically as the
firecracker to you know throw the chess
board up the whole thing the
administrative state or the deep state
or maybe you have a different phrase for
it this Steve say war is this idea of a
constant group of people that stay no
matter what administration comes and
goes can you just explain a little bit
about what that actually is lord have
mercy all right so folks who get their
those jobs you are there for 20 25 30
years and it's true that you out last
all administration's so what are these
jobs like let's really do like the most
base level here cuz this is the type of
thing you hear deep state and everyone
online here you're either a conspiracy
theorist or now it's Jones guy or give
me something like what are these people
actually doing right so when you live
let's take the CIA right so someone like
me who went in as an Operations Officer
so somebody basically goes out in the
field or Koontz buys and steal secrets
right you have a tremendous amount of
power right it's a tremendous number of
tools to read people's emails and some
people's phone calls you can call it
surveillance teams you have a lot of
power to do or accomplish the mission
and through that some people have this
mistaken belief that they are now
anointed to make decisions writ large in
terms of foreign policy that is they are
the ones that have the knowledge to
decide what the nation should or
shouldn't do on a particular issue
instead of simply informing a
policymaker to say here's what I know to
be true here's what I think we ought to
do but here are some different options
and you make the choice or the call
because you're representing the people
and I am simply a tool so basically they
sort of have access to all of this
information and then after years of it
you start thinking you're bigger that's
right the people that are coming and go
so one of the most infamous spies
Aldrich Ames worked with CIA but indeed
worked for the Russians secretly was
eventually found out a led to over 100
individuals assets being killed when he
was asked why he did it he said I know
what's best for the nation's foreign
policy and I'm gonna act on that so that
degree of hubris hmm right you go in
loving your country embracing the flag
you're there the CI for the right
reasons
but now suddenly you've come to this
belief that you are anointed that you
are somehow that the guardian of the
Republic beyond the the defensive nature
that that you the people your government
has has anointed on you to actually do
good things to support the Constitution
and and support policymakers now you
think that you're actually a king or a
queen behind the scenes and you will
move the levers of power and you will
decide who gets briefed on what pieces
of information or you don't briefed
certain pieces of information I'll give
you an example so I worked a that I
can't talk a ton about but an Asia
related concern and what we were
briefing the White House was that what
we's the CIA were doing in terms of
recorded action operations were
incredibly successful but I actually
knew that that wasn't true so I sat down
with the analysts and I said help me
understand why you all make this
judgment what we don't make that
judgment that we don't believe that's
true so I collated all this information
I presented it to our what we call the
seventh floor and I said you know sirs
what we are presenting to the White
House as effective isn't and they said
well you know either we this is the song
at dancing and then I said look I mean
you read that downtown right knowing
that I had absolutely no ability to do
that right so they just sort of it took
an issue that they knew would be
problematic for the agency for
themselves they lied about it to the NSC
into the White House and they decided
what was best for America's foreign
policy as it relates to that particular
country in that particular issue around
weapons of mass destruction so it's a
one it's a tiny little example of how
the deep state can decide what a nation
should or shouldn't do the rubric that I
think has been crossed
that's that kind of stuff is more
typical Washington what hasn't happened
in it is certainly my lifetime or my
recollection there's a guy like Brennan
and clapper deciding that a politician
or someone running this one president
Trump in this case
candidate Trump in this case was not
good enough to assume the presidency so
they were doing things to kneecap his
administration before or I should say
his election his ability to become
unelected official yeah can you can you
explain a little bit about what these
guys were doing so let's just start with
the dossier yeah all right because to me
yeah you've had tweets deleted over this
I mean Twitter tried to try to device
you and ban you because you started as a
former CIA guy you started talking about
what what Brandon was up to what they
what these guys were doing and they they
were gonna boot you off Twitter and then
eventually there was enough of an outcry
I tried to help as I could and you did
get you back on there now yeah so
alright if we just look at the dossier
what we knew for a considerable amount
of time that this information was
unvetted
and uncorroborated it was it was
internet rumor I think is what was an IG
report right so as well know that this
was garbage but yet it was utilized by
the FBI to continue surveillance of a
Trump campaign official so this is
before the election this dossier which
is basically an internet rumor is now
used so the CIA can use spying
techniques let me at least it down yeah
he had a foreign spy it was hired by a
domestic political opponent inject this
garbage into the system which if you
work in the intelligence field you know
that any Russian sources are oftentimes
controlled by Vladimir Putin the SVR
right so unless you really been there
there's a hard enough table Oh amazing
this is that he's Russian so we're
pumping this fake garbage that we
haven't vetted into the political system
we're using it for surveillance purposes
and now and here's the kicker in early
January of 2017
they clapper and comeon Brennan leaked
this dossier to the press which had
already been circulated out there but
giving it their stamp of we know it
exists and we're going to brief this
right Swee they briefed it to present
electrum and the very act of doing that
and saying hey you should be aware that
this exists suddenly gave the hook for
the press to run with this story that we
have a Russian agent sitting in the
White House the FBI and the CIA
you know they believed enough in this
dock
to brief it and then of course the fire
was said right the brush fire took off
yeah the hysteria was launched but
what's amazing is the next number of
days in the next couple of weeks every
one of those bastards call me and
clapper Brennan all of them said oh but
you know the dossier we don't believe it
I guess it's just it's just a real
murder well then why'd your briefing you
spread it around Washington because you
knew that it would cause a brush fire
you knew it would set this nation on
fire and you knew that the Trump
presidency would likely never recover
from it and in fact John Brennan told a
crowd here in Los Angeles that president
Trump would no longer be in office as an
interview he gave in at by the end of
2018 he told a bunch of these Hollywood
elites don't worry about it
Trump's gonna be gone by the end of 2018
thank God John Brennan was gone and now
he's under criminal investigation oh hey
Jabbar so that was my next question
Jessica how how nervous should clapper
and Brennan and Comey be I mean clapper
is the guy who lied under oath when they
asked him about are we you know doing
mass surveillance on people are in our
own citizens and what it was it not
wittingly right but he said as he was
scratching the top of his head would you
ever say that episode of Seinfeld you
know when you're lying the the higher up
with a face that you scratch all right
I'll see if it's a big lie or not I mean
he's literally going not witting right
right yet and I'm just know starts
growing yes but then becomes like a CNN
analyst on this and and suffers
ramifications for lying under oath how
much trouble do you think these guys
really that they're in a lot and I think
that they know it and I am as an
American forget my party affiliation
forget you having worked in the CIA
although that's a part of my anger
because I know what they've done to the
intelligence community they have now
made the American people reasonably
concerned about a degree of
politicization that they weren't aware
of one that they thought would be might
and be impossible so they have really so
lead and only the reputation but the
ability of the FBI and the CIA to go out
and do the good work that they need to
do we do in fact need an FBI SCA to do
the good work that they do but it's
reasonable for an American step back and
say maybe we shouldn't have these guys
because there's really highly
politicised so I think that Brennan and
Comey and clapper and that whole cabal
that was involved in these shenanigans
in 2016 should be very worried John
Durham a ver
very smart man and I think AG bar is
playing a long game on this one I think
he's letting Comey go on some of the
smaller stuff
I mean he's hitting him hard in some
areas and the IG has called him a you
know a dangerous man a man who's had a
dangerous precedent for the 30 plus
thousand former and current FBI
employees and I think you're gonna find
the same thing with with with clapper
and Brennan this is all over so if these
guys did so much bad stuff what do you
make of the fact that they don't shut up
like what do you make of the fact that
Comey wrote the book yeah you know which
nobody wants to the Helen teaches ethics
what is happening this world or look at
Brennan's Twitter feed yeah just like
wait a minute you were the CIA I don't
think you should be like you're
basically attacking one of the
institutions the office of the
presidency now I get at Trump attacks
everybody - so there's nobody that's
totally clean here but like I you know
you look at Brennan's Twitter feed and
it's like what what are you doing what
but they don't I guess they feel that
they'll never be caught well here's
here's I think what's happening you have
Co McLennan clapper and Brennan they're
all you know contributors they go to
these fancy you know functions and they
here in Los Angeles they belong to these
Institute's they go on Twitter and
they're all echoing the same talking
points which is basically Trump is a
Russian traitor or he's all but and we
have to get this guy out of the office
of the presidency and we as former CIA
FBI odni you know what three or four
letter agency they were part of we are
the defenders of the country we are the
defenders of the nation and so literally
what you were saying about that state
before right so so there's they're
spinning this over and over and over
again to continue this high boil of
hysteria so that people believe that the
Brennan's and the commis and the
clappers are actually good guys right
they're creating their hysterical base
so that when H G bar and Durham will
come out with this report
mark my words that you will have the
MSNBC's and the Rachel Maddow from the
top of the roof screening yeah but it's
partisan and it's not true and this is
just a party this is a witch-hunt
against them and they will deny facts so
it's coming so they're they're preparing
the battlefield very wisely although
horrifically that they're they're trying
to save their own skin and so that's
they're prepping the battlefield with
all of these hysterical tweets so that
they can
find a way at least in the public sphere
to to push back to save their skin all
right so I want to get to the media
portion of that because you've talked a
lot about how they leak things to the
media and the rest of that but before we
get that how pissed are these guys at
the Mueller for the report I mean they
they obviously didn't think this was
going to be the outcome and it was all
going to just be nonsense and make
Rachel Maddow look like a complete
ruining lunatic right so so no collusion
that was a surprise for the Democratic
Party wasn't it for the left that was a
slam dunk right that was supposed to be
a very clear case of a president being
you know a Russian agent and he wasn't
and it look it was appropriate it all
seemed like nonsense like what I kept
saying from the beginning was if if this
is all true wouldn't every Democrat be
saying we're in World War three now yeah
like let's really take this thing to
attend conclusion if it's really true
that in effect Russia basically
installed the Prez in the United States
I mean that's a as big a crime as you
could possibly get so congratulations
we're in World War 3 they're worried
about the New World War 3 but we're in
it already so I think that many of us do
include myself the very beginning were
concerned about the connections not just
the dossier related garbage because that
was silly but some of the rest of it and
it was like my position I think a lot of
us at the very beginning said look let
Bob Muller do a fair job within a short
period of time to address this issue
because what I knew working intelligence
community is if we had any information
any intelligence
SIGINT or human in other words phone
calls emails we had any kind of sources
from human beings multiple individuals
throughout the world in Moscow etc who
could all corroborate the same thing
then we need to know that and let's put
that forward but very quickly that
information should be brought to the
table and and we would be ejecting the
man from the White House within the
first few months of his presidency and
when that didn't happen they became very
clear to me and I think most reasonable
intelligence officials were former
officials that there was nothing there
that this was now getting into a
political exercise and I think that the
report showed that that there certainly
was no collusion now the issue of did he
try to obstruct well boy I think you can
take a step back and say look if I were
a newly elected president and I knew
that I was being smeared by a bunch of
former FBI and CIA
well in the media Santa was a Russian
agent I know that's not true damn right
I might try to shut down that
investigation because I know it's
garbage most reasonable people would
want to say forget it that's garbage I
know where you're trying to do you're
trying to politicize my ability to do
this work as presidented States you were
trying to make sure that I can't do what
the American people elected me to do
especially literally you were elected on
draining the swamp correct so that's
sort of the core thing here so the the
obstruction piece I think is is a
political loser I also think that that
the essence of the arguments garbage as
well but the Democratic Party has clung
to that and now that they see that that
wasn't working out and Bob Miller bless
his heart if you recall when he
testified the guy yeah he was sad I
actually felt bad for him I like I was
just way over his head or or he has a
little bit of the Biden sort of like are
you even all there right then I'm a good
man he I think he worked hard for his
country but he was way over skis doing
something he shouldn't he should have
stayed in in a retirement land so
alright so the other piece of this which
you've sort of been hitting on here is
the media portion and how all of these
leaks every day you open up the New York
Times or CNN or MSNBC and they're
reporting on stuff that's supposed to be
behind closed doors there are secret
congressional meetings about things but
somehow MSNBC in the New York Times has
all of ships talking points right right
and the rest of it how does this game
actually get played like is it as
obviously ridiculous
as and so I'm just so blatant as it
seems could it be that blatant yeah it
is look most of the leaking so that the
when you work in Washington you find out
very quickly that most of the leaking
occurs either by the White House
interestingly enough or by the senior
levels of the various departments and
agencies it's it's rarely that lower or
working level individual right it's the
people who again like Aldrich Ames have
decided that they know what's best for
the country so they're gonna act on
they're gonna leak things to try to push
the the media narrative and at one
direction or another based on whatever
they they want or their goals are or
personal goals we saw that Comey
we know he leaked in new york times via
cut out to try to push for an
independent council and he got it
so it's not as though this detect it
doesn't work it does work so that's
frightening
that's your frightened ho yes yeah
both sides doing but what we have seen
over the past four years is a group of
individuals from the FBI from the CIA
who are leaking pieces of information to
kneecap a duly elected president so that
they can put the people and power that
they choose irrespective of party
whether it's an ever Trumper or whether
it's one of these you know more
traditional moderate democrat what the
hell that means these days right well
it's not really irrespective of party
right because if you mean an ever
Trumper or some other Democrat sure I
mean historically the leaks have come
from both sides of the aisle to the
meeting because of their own personal
desire to shape policy right we're just
seeing it on steroids now yeah the
amount of leaking that the ferociousness
of the impact of those leaks right that
it's not just we like this where we
don't like this it's you know Trump is a
traitor or it's gonna launch this in a
world war three or it's that absurd is
that hysteria that that was kicked off
in 2016 and hasn't stopped do you think
that's partly just because we're just
watching institutions crumble across the
board and so they're all sort of in
their death throes so you just throw out
everything so you know what I mean like
we're watching our media institutions
crumble our political institutions are
crumbling we're exposing information
conversations like this weren't really
being had five years ago so as it all
becomes more obvious the ways it can
lash out become crazier so as the
curtain is pulled back and The Wizard of
Oz just you not get a little bit more
panicked understanding is like four foot
250 pounds yeah I think the tech could
explain a lot because again at some
level when you start looking at for
instance let's just take the media right
so it's long been known that the media
focuses on one particular party and
benefiting that and it's a democratic
party which by the way when you get like
95% of the political funds or that is
the media supports you like from their
political donations it's incredible that
the Republican Party even exists yeah
you have that degree of an avalanche of
support in your nation's media the fact
that another party exists is really
incredible or it means a demo reminder
I'm looking at a lifelong Democratic I
say that again so look in the last 10 to
15 years forget that five years yeah
we'll get to that yeah we're gonna go
but ya know I think you're right to say
that the media is recognizing that we're
all pulling off the mask and
who they are and that is horrifying to
them because the moment that we start
questioning their authority to tell us
what's right and wrong and we start
saying you know what actually you've
given to that the other political party
used to work for that other you know
organization or entity that is now
against Trump or like we now know that
you were bison and that's fine right you
and I both have an opinion we both go on
TV to talk about things in our opinions
that's fine but let's be candid about
who we are and what we believe in and
it's not pass it as news because it's
not news it's just an opinion
right it's interesting of the former
editor of New York Times give this
fantastic interview but she talked about
her students and she left the New York
Times now I believe it's at Yale or one
of these fancy Ivy's and she works with
students who want to become journalists
and she said one of the frustrations
that she has is that they all want to
report on their own opinions of what's
happened in the world right in and not
the news and it's like well amen we have
been walking down this road for 15 plus
years where everybody in the right was
it it yeah so so let's have an honest
conversation that the Walter Cronkite's
are gone yeah and it's and it's now you
know a circus and it's everybody's got a
different performer that they prefer and
that's bad and we should acknowledge
that that's bad and we should I think as
a country and at some point you know at
when does journalism ring its own bell
and say we've got too far let's see if
we can do something nervous so when you
read the paper that was formerly the New
York Times are there phrases that you
can see are obvious tells when it's
complete nonsense beyond just unnamed
source or source I mean just picking it
up and it's saying putting it back down
yeah yeah by the way as I always say
every time I talk the New York Times I
would prefer this not be the case amen
everyone everyone does it the people
that I find that are railing against it
the most
yeah are the people that don't want this
to be the most yes I already just don't
be totally horrible I come from the
middle of nowhere in Eastern Oregon the
way that I was able to get into the CIA
was that I went to Washington Post in
New York Times I read it every single
day back in the late nineties and early
2000s I took notes on each stories I
built you know my knowledge
understanding the world based on their
reporting so there was a time when I was
a big fan and I appreciated what that
they they were doing for for me for the
for the world of countries spreading you
know what was actually happening and
we've lost that
the very lady and and Washington Post
has gone even more bananas and bars it's
horrible for the Republic because
democracies need that voice to challenge
people in power and so do you think
we're more than anything else by me
putting all the political stuff aside
maybe putting deep state aside putting
the parties aside that we're really more
in an information war at this point than
anything else
it's not even information it's really
the delivery system of the information
sure anything else I mean you're talking
to a guy who put out two tweets
expressed a political opinion no
inflammatory language can you just
remind me what the tweets were exactly
because it's kind of you're a former CIA
ops guy I think you've proven here these
this half hour or whatever it is that
you know what you're talking about here
the the two tweets that you put up so
both of them basically had to do with
President Trump or Democrats being crazy
and one was taking a headline from The
Washington Post which was silly parsing
flim-flam didn't matter what the hell
the headline was I was just commenting
on the fact that was silly and that was
enough to get me banned for whatever
number of days right the other was a
thread talking about the president and
you know what we are
this whole impeachment silliness and how
absurd it is and it was a relatively
short thread and it was bad again simply
taking a snippet from the IG report and
commenting on that section report that
was enough so that to me and I know that
you you have been banging this drum for
a long time is incredibly frightening
that we now have a handful of entities
from Silicon Valley that are really
publishers deciding who gets to say
whatever they want them to say and if it
goes too far either as a corporate
policy or as a you know one off whatever
a number of employees decide that's bad
they're gonna throw a little sand in the
gears right they may not bang you
completely they may but they may just
throw some sand in the gears and have
you blocked for a week or two or
whatever when you want to share
something a very important time a
nation's politics right there during
this Iran you know issue right so where
throw some sand and your gears we're
gonna stop you from tweeting us stop you
from sharing something on Facebook
that's what they're doing now that's
what they've done to me does it feel
like the whole game
is designed to just make us crazier
right now like every time like once you
start seeing this stuff right you have
your little red pill moment you start
seeing this stuff you don't want to see
it right you want to put the ocean back
in the cup right and it just doesn't fit
well I think that this has been a long
time coming so what's interesting is MIT
did this brilliant study that in the
late 90s when some of our economic trade
policies were changing [ __ ] to WTO
we had Mexico and Canada and NAFTA and a
lot of the communities were being
impacted negatively by these economic
changes we're starting to elect people
to Congress and and and Senate who were
increasingly more inflammatory
increasingly further on the left and
further on the right and and what you
now see that that created a marketplace
for people immediate to be even more
loud and bombastic and crazy because
people were angry and so they were able
to tap into that marketplace right so I
think that the things that you're seeing
in America's media right now are really
reflective of a country that's deeply
unsettled it doesn't mean that we don't
celebrate the progress here in this
country because economically I don't
think you can make an argument and
you've had people in this partner that
made it very clear that we are
benefitting profoundly from our
wonderful economic system imperfect as
it is our wonderful republic and perfect
as it is but there's clearly a sickness
that is being reflected in our media
that is really at the end of the day it
reflects our own brokenness our own
anger because we're so we're responding
in such a visceral way we're giving
those people radiance all right so let's
go to our wars be beat-up lefty guys
here for a second yes as you're saying
that I'm reminded of when I used to be
on The Young Turks and I was a big lefty
now that I'd be on air with the hosts
and they'd be screaming like crazy
people about something there's no
there's no video of me ever screaming
about anything like this but they'd be
screaming saying and then we cut to
break and then they'd be completely fine
again like completely fine
then we come back and people screaming
right and we're crying or yelling there
I survived and I don't everything like
this is just all theater yeah like this
is not theater to me I'm happy we're
having the same exact conversation right
now that we were having before the
cameras started to write and everything
else but we've been sort of primed that
everything is is sort of theater right
now but it doesn't seem like we can we
can get any of this
like is that is that now where we're at
like that it won't come back so what I'm
talking about with the cup and the ocean
it's like we now need different
institutions I think there's a lot of
people trying to hang on to the old
institutions I see this with a lot of my
last remaining saying lefty friends like
they really want the new the New York
Times will come back the Democratic
Party will come back but they ain't
coming back guys
if if there's any hope its president
Trump wins in 2020 and the Democrat and
the deathblow is so right Cataclysm and
loss both the house ascent in the
presidency you know we would be talking
about like 1984 election with Mondale
and 88 election with Dukakis but you
know let's not forget that that stupid
tends to be very resilient and so you're
seeing a lot of that coming out of
places like New York with the causing of
Cortes we're getting a lot of very crazy
individuals who are very now powerful
within the Democratic Party we're
absolutely reshaping it you would need
to have a progressive nominated for the
2020 election lose against President
Trump so they have to have their Corbin
basic yeah yeah yeah I mean I see that
is I mean how crazy though for two guys
that are basically lifelong Democrats
and I can't call myself part of the left
anymore but I'm hanging on by I get my
fingernails ya know but a lot of my good
last liberal friends are trying like I
get it and it's just like for me the
ship has sailed it's fine but you wrote
a piece in prop life raft for those of
us here to paddle on behind you I'm
gonna keep it out there but not much I
gotta go now yeah well I feel like I've
been screaming about this for so long
that now it's weird because you know
your frustrations change over time and
it's like I used to be really frustrated
with the right and then for these last
couple years I've been frustrated with
left now I'm like really frustrated at
my last remaining lefty friends that
just refused to see reality cuz it's
like come on guys like how much how much
more destruction do you want these
people to so there how much further down
the socialist path do you want to go but
the but you wrote a piece about this in
in Fox News I mean do you think there's
any chance i coul who are the remaining
democrats that would make someone like
you say you're a Democrat or the or the
forget the people although you're
welcome to tell me some what are the
Democratic policies that actually make
any sense anymore so if you
look at if you believe Gallup polling so
about 15% of Democrats are conservative
Democrats are identifies conservative
Democrats 35 say they're moderate and
50% say liberal progressive so there is
clearly a split within the party I think
what you're seeing now in places like
Iowa and New Hampshire and South
Carolina and Nevada it's on that polling
and Biden still got the pole position
but clearly if you look at Bernie
Sanders into someone lesser extent
Elizabeth Warren that wing of the party
is strong and so what happens in this
primary season I think will set the
temperature in the direction for the
party for many many years to come and
that's why you're seeing people like
Acacio Cortez just yesterday say in an
interview that she can't believe that
she invited her both part of the same
party well because that was the plan all
along she's not a Democrat Bernie
Sanders is not a Democrat they're
democratic socialists which of course as
you have they're gonna drop the
Democratic Party somebody words go
north Korea has calls himself the
Democratic People's Republic of Korea so
if there is a branding exercise that
right it's beer brand ago so it it's it
really there's so there's some chutzpah
happening right now we are the the the
socially socialist wing of the party
basically saying that they are the party
so that fight is gonna continue to 2020
let's see what happens my personal hope
and I and I hate to say this but my
personal hope is that we elect some
crazy progressive elect Bernie Sanders
right then the American people have a
very clear distinction of whip for whom
they should choose what should the
future of the country
look like is it the Bernie Sanders and
then the green New Deal's and the freed
you know everything that nobody can pay
for right and then this is absurd plus
all the racism yes the Olympics yeah so
is that who we want to become and if
it's not then you have to vote for the
other guy cuz you only have two choices
but do you think there's any mechanism
and this is the thought that I've really
been stuck on for last couple months
like is there any mechanism that
liberals have I mean good liberals right
so like an old-school Democrat has to
fight off the bad thing because we're
just watching all of them be pinned one
at a time you know to me like Biden was
brought in to
you the the straight shooter and the
decent guy and the old-school Democrat
now he's telling you you can pick which
prison you want to go to and learn how
to code is coal miners he literally yeah
not learn how to code coal miners and
then and then his other thing the other
day about for Western team yeah yeah but
but oh I thought cuz he had this other
thing the other day about you know we're
basically said we're a European culture
not at some culture that's been imported
from Africa and it's like I thought
that's what it's about what but he was
brought in to be the doctor I'm saying
like there's no mechanism for a decent
Democrat anymore there's no vehicle for
anymore no there's not right because
it's some level you would hope that the
media or people within you know the
Washington Post New York Times and the
CNN's and MSNBC said they would have
some little more sensible voices and
calling out the people like Ocasio
Cortez and Bernie Sanders saying they're
not real Democrats let's talk about
their strategy document from 2012 the
talks about Marx and Lenin and and
taking over the economy let's talk about
who they are
versus the joy Behar's the view of like
she's super awesome yeah you know and
Rachel Maddow of like more she's an
impressive gal like what is happening
like I don't care that she can dance
really fun on a roof in Boston like that
stupid viral video like that's not
important the fact that she wants to
encourage United States government to
take over the means of production in
this in this country you're socialism
you say yeah right look let's up in that
and let's pass the new Green Deal which
we could never afford and oh by the way
isn't actually going to be effective
right so let's slaughter all the cows
because of the cow farts okay super you
are aware that China and India their
combined co2 and methane emissions will
far and do far eclipse everything that
the United States and European Union
could ever do in terms of their horrific
pollution so you can call it the cows
you want but until you address the India
and China problem this is silly this is
a silly conversation and the only
reasonable people in this conversation
right now chuckling of are Republicans
it's the damn Crenshaw's who are like
yeah look co2 and methane it's an it's
real like it's happening and we need to
focus on Rd related issues that scrub
the stuff out of the environment
that's what we need to be doing versus
knocking down Enver every house
rebuilding it killing all the farting
cows like if you're gonna go 40 people
killed
what about swallow yeah he goes on TV
and farts I thought about that guy you
know yeah that was the biggest part of
2019 that was that was an amazing series
of flatulence yeah lifted right he
actually has like I don't know he said
it would they said it was a cup right
note is a comp on shore on the table
sure and so I use that excuse to yeah
yeah so alright if they go down that
road and then okay now Bernie let's just
say it's Bernie right how's that the
easier answer here
Bernie ends up getting crushed and then
we have round two of Trump you think
there's a chance they actually
recalibrate and look in the mirror and
do it because they've had me Trump's
president now like a-tryin at every
moment and this is where my frustration
lies where there have been every moment
when those roadblocks have come of like
guys let's take the look now they always
just plow right through and I sense that
that's exactly what they're do I sense
that's what they're gonna do in in the
UK now like it just it doesn't stop it
shows and stuff the question is are we
at the point where leftism is so broken
that we double down
so we have our Mondale moment and we're
just gonna go with Dukakis or we at the
Bill Clinton 92 moment where the powers
of being a Democratic Party say okay we
dipped our topics in the crazy waters
but let's let's do something different
now and I I think that we are more at
our 84 moment and I think that we're
gonna double down on stupid because I
think that the fever is too strong look
Tom Perez the DNC said that Ocasio
Cortes is the future the party Barack
Obama endorsed her during her election
you know he's now endorsed Medicare for
all I mean this is a man who at the same
time also talks about you know you need
to not go too far to the left well then
why the holy hell are you endorsing
socialist he plays it both sides every
other one comes out with something that
sounds you know we shouldn't judge
people by the color of their skin and
then women should rule the world that
it's like pick a side so that we are in
the middle of silly season and it's not
just the deep why is this important
right so this conversation about where
is the left today why should we really
care the people who are watching this
we're Republicans or libertarian
like yeah why do they keep emailing in
there they keep saying Dave stop giving
them the right right you know but here's
what I would say to them and this is
what I would say to any of us who are
tired of the left
you know silliness but well will this
all vote for Trump right we are not
China with one party
we are not North Korea with one Dear
Leader a republic a true democracy
requires vibrant parties to combat each
other to fight with each other
rhetorically to provide different
solutions to problems right so you need
a vibrant political class to have these
conversations because at the end of the
day this is so important because who
else is going to lead humanity for the
next number of years for the next
century it's not going to be China it's
not going to be russia and god forbid if
either of those two nations are leading
humanity so is that the irony here that
when when people want us to pull out of
everything and I get that my libertarian
side really feels that and why are we
giving all these countries money and if
you told me right now we were gonna cut
foreign aid 25 percent across the board
I probably before it I don't know all of
the ramifications of all of those things
and I'm sure that would talk about
foreign aid - yes all right so let's
talk about it then but like so like that
part of me really exists but then it's
like it's not just that we'd pull back
and then things would just keep
operating it's like well somebody's
gonna step in correct and who do we want
to step into as imperfect as we are I
kinda would rather it be us it's just
our sort of Faustian bargain with the
university something well so look from a
foreign policy perspective you know
people talk about what's our strategy
but our strategy well we want to create
more democracies and then we want to try
to stop or slow down or bog down to
parties who would stop us humanity from
reaching that point of greater Liberty
right because that is ultimately the
goal and we are the torchbearers about
legacy you say that so you hit on this
earlier but when you say that the idea
that we're giving them more Liberty we
want more democracies because
democracies don't get into wars with
each other it's not purely like I think
when people say that you want to spread
democracy there's somehow it means this
sort of financial writing or capitalist
thing but it actually is I mean this is
I don't know if you read virtue and
nationalism by your own Arizona
it's like strong nations actually strong
democratic nations that's what actually
brings P
correct absolutely and this has been
again foreign policy 101 this has been a
profound goal of most United States
presidents and the administration's
so yes we have to be involved in engaged
in different parts of the world where it
suits our interests particularly whether
it be economic and so forth again this
is the Trump's like what are we getting
give us her oil stuff right he's using
crass language but they request is fair
but in places where China or Russia that
don't represent that the future of
humanity in the way that I think you and
I would want all of us to be like if
they're they're underwriting you know
corrupt regimes all over the world
certainly China definitely in places
like Africa what can we do to slow down
their reach and their power because that
that is important without committing a
ton of our resources our people and our
treasure to that right and then it
becomes sort of a strategic engagement
or would draw from different parts of
the world because oftentimes is aid
really the end of the day we're just
we're paying people off to keep the you
know the Russians out the Chinese have
work to try to keep it a little boil but
not encouraging corruption right so that
can be a very difficult thing to balance
but I know they're gonna get a lot of
corruption just but correct so you have
to constantly keep a pulse on that right
so it's it's not it's not easy to do
this but I will tell you I've seen these
aid projects in places like saying
Zambia where we're giving them or all
this money for instance where some of
the tribes or we're giving them a lots
of money to build fish ponds and yet
you've got the world you know these
other NGOs coming in and delivering food
and so all the fish died and it ponds go
drive it's like well of course because
you're just you're giving people food
we're not going to slip out in this
terrible heat and like work of course or
not so we sometimes we are we do things
are silly with our aid but the broader
point the most important thing that we
have to remember from the foreign policy
perspective is we're trying to create
more democracies that's going to be a
long loop process is not going to happen
by the barrel of a gun and it's not
gonna happen to tomorrow so let's have
some patience and then where we are
engaged in the world especially when it
comes to our military damn right there
better be something that the American
people are getting in return because it
can't be this constant outlay and that's
what I think you're seeing
guys like Tucker Carlson and others be
you know very reluctant about our
contained engagement in at least so
change your energy policy make them
irrelevant and now you can march forward
you know it's interesting that you bring
up Tucker there because you know I see
this sort of split now where Trump you
know did the the strike and run and now
suddenly Tucker said well this is gonna
lead us a role of are three Trump's
kinda just like everybody else yeah and
I like Tucker very much obviously but I
thought while everyone's sort of jumping
all over that like I see this horrible
split that's occurred and oh my god
right to me it's like this is great
right this is what a great debate is
happening on the right right now right
you know can you do a strike does that
lead to World War three like what a
beautiful thing it's like where would
that happen on the Left these days
without someone being just completely
slaughtered in the in the cross well
let's talk about what the democratic
party's done in the last three or six
months about these are so in terms of
foreign engagement like so Trump wants
to withdraw from Syria and you know he's
an idiot right remember that
conversation and now he's sending people
into Iraq and well now he's an idiot
well what is it what do you guys want
what is your strategy on the Left I mean
I would love to hear that I mean we know
what Joe Biden likes to do with in terms
of some of his foreign policy stuff he's
been wrong more times than he's been
right then he sends his kid and and
blesses his engagement with the corrupt
Ukrainian oligarch and takes it oh let's
let's could we just finish with that
actually that's the right way defend I
meant to get it to it before we did the
Russia stuff so the Ukraine stuff and
and an impeachment and everything else
is the basic takeaway here beyond the
obvious stuff that everyone sees on the
headlines like how insane it was that
hunter Biden is getting was it 50 grand
a month yeah sure whatever something is
saying to work for an energy company he
had no expertise in blah blah blah does
that happen to be vice president okay
that what it seems that this all hinges
on the idea that if Trump felt
legitimately that there was corruption
which there clearly was like nobody's
really debating whether something
seriously corrupt was going on Jake
Tapper said minuteness on his program
loved it Jake it's like 50/50 it's like
one day I'm like Jake you get it the
next day house does it's my enviros but
it seems that it all hinges on the idea
that if Trump genuinely believed that
there was corruption and I think every
sane person believes that there was
corruption then he had thought he had
the woods all three were the
Legation absolutely - to actually do
something about it is that is that did I
get this thing kind of right yes right
and if you look at polling even if I
think it's some forty some odd percent
of Democrats actually think that what
the Biden's did was wrong and deserves a
degree of scrutiny so you've got a good
chunk of the party darn near half that
think that and of course independents
and Republicans are fully on board with
that so that's the fundamental problem
with this impeachment push is if the
president if there was nothing there if
the binds did absolutely nothing wrong
then of course Trump would have been
absolutely horrific ly wrong to ask them
to get involved in our politics or or
trying to kneecap byun or any other
person but that's not the case we know
unquestionably just based on what we
know from press reports yeah and from we
now have testimony by an Obama
administration diplomat as early as 2015
they were racing the flag in Kiev saying
hey look what the Biden kids doing is
undercutting our ability to fight
corruption in Ukraine and they were
holding you basically shut the hell up
well what about that incredible video of
Biden just admitting the whole thing
well it's it's all scam right it's all a
joke it's all a scam and this is when I
want like out there like show ridiculous
let's just put out there yeah this is
what I want oh I like I want to channel
my inner Trump an NBA I get so much on
that's all scam yeah because it is it's
silly the Biden's did things that were
inappropriate and wrong and they should
have been investigated whether it be by
the Ukrainians whether we are by our
department justice or both it's
absolutely enough is there for us to say
that was wrong and it should be
investigated and the fact that the
president's being called on the carpet
for this and impeached over his demand
to look into it I think is absurd put in
a committee investigated the other day
but to actually watch an impeachment and
put this country through something that
is just silly it's it's it's absolutely
horrific ly wrong in the Democratic
Party and shame on Pelosi and Shore and
the legacy of the past five ten years
for what has happened under the
progressive leadership I think you were
going to look back and say what is what
a sorrowful time for this country well
congratulations because for as a
Democrat that thinks Trump that has it
has to be re-elected to get this thing
to reset I'm pretty sure if you ever
wanted to fire up the Trump base you
just did it with a partisan impeachment
but what do you make of now the fact
that they're not even sending this to
the Senate so they do a completely
partisan arrangement right complete
partisan Trump is
not a Nazi guy right i mean he's Hitler
yes we were all on this no hold on the
paperwork we are living in Nazi Germany
the equivalent of modern-day right we're
putting kids in cages and Trump is
Hitler right but you know what let's sit
back for a while I sit back in this
impeachment stuff for just a little bit
it's thinking about this rule like go go
to hell that's just absurd and it defies
logic it defies reason if you're gonna
move forward you better have the facts
and then let the American people make
that call have you heard the crazy
theory that she's gonna sit on it long
enough that Pelosi will stare on it long
enough so that assuming Trump's get
Trump gets reelected yeah and then but
maybe something happens in the Senate
more favorably to the Democrats yeah
then you move on at that I mean true
insanity
well if that's like gee maybe I mean if
if that's Pelosi's ballgame I'll tell
you what I think she's she's gonna be
disappointed come next November because
I in doing that she looks so flippin
absurd that most reasonable voters say
these folks aren't serious they're not
being adults right now you can have
differences with the administration with
Trump in terms of his temperament in
terms of some of his policies that's
fine make the case but this kind of
stuff either if I'm a
shit-or-get-off-the-pot right move the
impeachment forward and move them out of
office let the Senate judge and if they
don't tough you've done your part House
move on now make the case of the
American people I think you've proven
why I consider you one of the few sane
people on Twitter here so I'm gonna tell
the good people to follow you on twitter
it's Brian be rya and dean d en w RI GH
d thanks for coming in we're gonna have
to do this again anyway i got it once
you move once you officially are like
left done Democrat yeah and I think what
some nails brother at Brian Dean right
on Twitter if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell